[Music]
well la like a star Metta World Peace
was supposed to be a guest on our show
tonight and as anyone will tell you from
the Middle East
world peace harder to get a hold of than
you would think unfortunately a couple
of hours before showtime he canceled why
why would he do this well of course he
canceled because he's in a lot of
trouble for elbowing James Harden of the
Oklahoma City Thunder during Sunday's
game and I think we've all seen this
footage this is the footage of the
incident there it is he hit him and
there it is and oh yeah out of the
screws
yeah now Metta World Peace in a lot of
trouble yeah cuz it's not hockey you're
not allowed to do that hockey that's
encouraged yes he'd have a Stanley Cup
if this was hockey he might be facing a
long suspension big fines and of course
much worse he missed a chance to be on
my show which is that's a career ender
right there probably won't recover from
that no here's the thing I don't see
what the big deal is I really don't this
kind of thing happens all the time
during our show it does it happened
during the monologue I was telling a
joke just last week and the same thing
happened check this out okay of course
it's been eight years so her breasts no
longer hold up in court the joke
yeah and I got a big laugh and I'm
really pumped up really I mean it Andy
makes a classic mistake he gets right in
my zone don't get in my zone
and he goes down
[Applause]
there's another angle
there's one more angle right there
I don't know why you got in my zone I
don't remember what the big things I'm
not proud of what I did after Andy went
down that part
[Applause]
[Music]
where did I think I was running I don't
know a shocking statistic came out in
the news today you want to hear this so
I got all right here we go
you gotta be better than that you want
to hear this you overdid it a little bit
no for the first time in 40 years did
you know this more Mexicans are leaving
the united states that are coming to it
yeah that's true
yeah not because of our economy because
they're sick and tired of explaining
that Taco Bell isn't real Mexican food
it may not be real food
their response are yeah real good yeah
ladies and gentleman Megan Fox is
pregnant yeah Megan Fox is pregnant yeah
which is weird cuz I didn't know I could
impregnate someone with my thoughts
huh watch out ladies I'm sorry that guy
sorry I cut creepy real fast
[Laughter]
okay Secret Service scandal continues
political analysts are saying that
President Obama doesn't want to be too
critical of the Secret Service because
their agents protect him every day yeah
which explains why today President Obama
called the agent who refused to pay the
prostitute fiscally responsible not
worth it Newt Gingrich nobody likes the
idea of shortchanging hookers now
[Applause]
crowd enraged by that oh that's not
funny no not funny at all those girls
work hard they work hard hey Newt
Gingrich is reportedly struggling with
the question of dropping out of the
presidential race he's struggling yeah
okay Gingrich said if there's one thing
my two ex-wives know about me it's that
I'm not a quitter no please hold your
applause on the campaign trail Mitt
Romney said I love this I live for
laughter then he looked at his poll
numbers among women and had a two-hour
giggle fit
[Applause]